so in the last section we saw that our
new algorithm based off of the
leaderboard and cut method is worked
well on a spectrum that was close to the
correct theoretical spectrum but once we
had twenty five percent false and
missing masses it didn't reconstruct the
correct tire setting v1 peptide I want
to add some more bad news to that in
this section which is that these nrps
these non ribosomal peptides including
tire sitting be one they in practice
will contain more non standard amino
acids that are outside of the standard
genetic code and this is because they're
outside of the central dogma so for
example here is a relative of tired
sitting be one called tire sitting be
and it's very similar to tired sitting
be one except you'll notice that in this
position it has an amino acid called for
nothing and this is a non-standard one
and so to deal with these non-standard
amino acids because there are so many of
them what violent fermentations is suman
sometimes and what we assume here is
that any integer between 57 and 200 can
act as the mass of an amino acid right
so we've expanded now our integer mass
alphabet from 18 masses to a hundred and
forty-four amino acids by making this
assumption so then our question is okay
we expand our alphabet and now we have
to deal with a larger class of peptides
let's run our leaderboard cyclic peptide
sequencing algorithm on this expanded
alphabet to this spectrum ten with ten
percent false and missing masses now
remember before when we assume the
standard alphabet it reconstructed the
tire sitting be one correctly but here
when we expand the alphabet out to 144
amino acids the algorithm now identifies
the highest-scoring peptide as this
peptide and it incorporates 98 and 65
into the peptide so it doesn't
reconstruct the peptide correctly and
notice that it's brought in to non
standard amino acids the key point here
is that although tire sitting be one
doesn't actually contain any of these
non-standard amino acids we won't know
that when we're doing sequencing
experiments so we need to take them into
account and in this case the
algorithm would tell us that it has non
standard amino acids in it and that's
not good because it doesn't